hey guys it is friday friday the 13th in
fact although no amount of superstition
will keep me from telling you what
happened in gaming this week so let's
get right to that that approach dread
have confirmed the blood and wine will
definitely be the last expansion for the
witcher 3 wild hunt the developer have
confirmed they're shifting resources
over to cyberpunk 2077 although they
will still be releasing patches to fix
bugs in the main which is three game and
its expansions it's been suggested that
a patch will arrive before blood and
wine with a possible second update
coming after the expansion is launched
the 30-hour blood and wine expansion
will arrive on me 31 for pc ps4 and xbox
one last week battlefield one was
announced and the week before we got our
first look at call of duty infinite
warfare and the reception each one has
gotten has been very very different to
say the least at the time of writing the
battlefield one trailer has 1.4 2
million likes on YouTube which makes it
the most liked trailer ever and falls
just behind lady gaga's bad romance as
one of the most liked YouTube videos of
all times on the other side of the fence
call of duty infinite warfare has
garnered 1.9 million dislikes over the
last two weeks making it the fourth most
disliked video in youtube history it's
beaten by justin bieber's baby and
friday by rebecca black but is well
ahead of Psy's Gangnam style call Judy
infinite warfare is due out Omnicom
before while battlefield one will be out
on october 21 EA has confirmed that star
wars battlefront 2 is on the way a
double feature content from the new film
EA CFO Blake Jorgensen confirmed the
news during an earnings call and also
mentioned the battlefront two will have
bigger and better world the first
battlefront only featured content from
the original Star Wars trilogy Jorgensen
said ëi will be releasing one new star
wars game every year for the next three
to four years with the battlefront
sequel expected to land next year he
added that the star was action game
Visceral Games and motive studios will
also be out next year games but have
been in touch to confirm whether your
organ ssin was referring to the calendar
year or the fiscal year which begins in
April in other big game announcements
civilization 6 has been revealed and
it's aiming to change the way you place
it in the new game your cities will be
spread across multiple tiles instead of
stacked on one you can divide your
cities into districts and exploit your
enemies districts by attacking the areas
that are most likely to [ __ ] their
forces economy or resource production
firaxis has said they hope to encourage
players to play and build differently
every time with these new factors and
hope to provide a new layer of strategy
to warfare the developer are also making
changes to the way research multiplayer
and diplomacy work you can check out all
the nitty-gritty details in a story on
site and finally inside news this week
Disney has announced that it is
discontinuing its game business shutting
down avalanche studios and disney
infinity according to The Wall Street
Journal's been fritz close to 300 jobs
have been lost as a result it's not yet
known whether the closure is likely to
affect Disney Co developers like a ninja
theory the most recent game was Disney
infinity 3.0 which came out in August
2015 Disney said they did not plan to
launch four-point-oh this year but would
continue to update 3 point out to more
infinity playsets are due in June though
it appears these will be the last Disney
told gamespot the company plan to move
to a licensing model exclusively since
the niche toys to life market and high
production costs of Disney infinity
proved to be a challenging business
model our thoughts go out to everyone
affected by the studio closure that is
everything I have to you this week but
we should let me know what you thought
of this week stories are down in that
comment section this week on site I head
off to try and be Nathan Drake for a day
Lucy Ponder's what it would be like to
live on Mars and we check out the first
40 minutes of zoom thanks for tuning in
yet again as always be sure to have
yourselves a lovely weekend and I will
see you again